hello everyone and welcome to this
session
about the new java 11 runtime for cloud
functions
java is a very important and widely used
programming language in the enterprise
and customers have asked for java
support ever since we released the the
first
runtime for google cloud functions so
let's dive into
java 11 for cloud functions and that's
my pleasure to introduce you to my
colleague emman
hi i'm eamon mcmanus i'm the lead
developer for gcf java
and i'm guillaume laforge i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud and
i'm focusing on our serverless solutions
i also contributed to the java api for
this runtime so
i'm very excited to share that with you
so let's start with a few words about
the serverless concept
more than just a buzzword serverless is
both about
an operational and a programming
perspective
from an operational standpoint
developers can focus
on their code and don't need to bother
about servers to manage
clusters to provision it's a pay for
usage model so you pay
proportionately to the number of times
your functions
are invoked or the their duration so
you really pay only for the underlying
infrastructure when it's actually
used for your workloads not when it's
idle
for the programming model developers are
encouraged to
write more granular services instead of
the good old big
monolith and functions react to events
so whether it's an http call or it's
some events coming from your cloud
infrastructure
furthermore we've been building cloud
functions with an open approach
so we'll tell you more about this with
the functions framework
and you can easily run your functions
elsewhere
not just uh in the cloud but also on
your local machine
which improves the developer experience
as well as anywhere else
on premises or even in other in other
clouds potentially
so google cloud offers three serverless
compute solutions so there's cloud
functions which is the topic
of the day where you write even driven
services a small unit of code
there's app engine for deploying your
web application your services your
backend
apis like mobile mobile backends and
there's cloudrin where you can deploy
anything within a container
with any long wait that you want any
runtime any executable
you want to use now zooming back onto
cloud functions
there were so far only three runtimes
available
so there's node.js python and go
and today we're also happy to have java
11 which is available
in beta let's now have a look at the
types and shape of functions and i let
emon tell you all about our java
function
api thanks you so there's basically two
kinds of functions and this is true for
all of the different language runtimes
on gcf
there are http functions and background
functions so http functions
uh are react to a url being accessed so
it's a public url subject to access
controls
and whenever there's an http request
made to that url
the function gets executed and it can
specify what the reply to the http
request is going to be
and then there's background functions
and those are invoked by the system in
response to certain events and so we see
here
some of the events that that might be
for example pub sub events
or a file gets created in cloud storage
and so on
so uh java doesn't really have a notion
of functions as such
so the approach that we chose was a
familiar one for java which is to define
an interface that has a single method
and then your function is an
implementation of that interface so it
has
that method in it so when we look at
http functions
uh the interface in question is called
http function
um typically you would just type
something like in your ide class
example implements http function and
then you would ask basically get the ide
to fill in the details it knows
that that interface has one method so it
provides that method for you you don't
have to remember the method signature
and then all you need to do is implement
that method and it's unsurprising
there's a request parameter that allows
you to see the details of the incoming
http request
like what the url was the query
parameters if there's a body of what
that was
and then there's a response parameter
that allows you to say what the http
response is going to look like
the status code the content type
the body of that and so on let's have a
look at a slightly more complex
function an http function
so i'm defining a new class in a package
i'm importing the key functions
framework apis
the http function interface http request
and response
and in this example we're going to check
whether
a number is prime or not so we're going
to use an external dependency
here we're going to use um apache
commands math
and particularly the uh the primes
class which gives us the ability to know
if a number is prime or not so
let's implement the http function
interface and
overwrite the service method the service
method takes
an http request and an http response
here you can see on the response object
i can
for example set the status code 200
set the content type here it's just some
some plain text
and i can also get the writer to write
on the output
on the request on the request object i
can call
get first query parameter to get the
query parameters in this case
that's the number that is passed as a
parameter
um if there's no number uh you don't
necessarily
know so this method actually returns an
optional
so if there's a number that is present
then i can have some
logic and otherwise i'm going to say
okay please provide a number
so if a number is provided i'm going to
look at this number um it's actually a
string
it's part of the query string so i'm
going to turn that string
into an integer in the in value
variable and then i'm going to say okay
is this value
a prime number and then i call the the
dependency
uh from the the primes class
primes is prime with the value so i'm
going to
return a boolean value whether it's
prime or not
and if there was a parsing error from
the query string
i'm going to write please provide a
valid number
and let's have a look at the build here
i'm building with
maven so i'm saying okay i'm using
java 11 and here you can see
the two dependencies the dependency on
the functions framework api
with the provided scope because the
environment
on the the cloud functions runtime
provides
this api and i have my
my user dependency on apache commands
math
and now let's have a look at how to run
this
so please provide a number if i don't
provide any number
so let's add a number here
abc oh please provide a valid number
so let's do it again but with one two
three
four so is this number
prime it's false so let's say let's try
it with another number
17 is 17 prime yes that's true
so here's our first http function
so we saw http functions what about
background functions
um the way the background functions work
behind the scenes is that you still have
incoming http but you don't have to be
concerned with it anymore
so the http has a payload which is a
json payload
and we can consider that comes in two
parts there is essentially an envelope
which is the things that are common to
all kinds of events and that says
what the event type is what the
timestamp is and so on and then there's
the content which is
the things that are specific to the
particular event that you're receiving
then there are two ways of handling
these and they're quite similar
um they just have to do with uh how
the json is presented to you so in both
cases
that the envelope will be
parsed for you you don't have to see how
that's represented in json that's the
second parameter to these functions
the first parameter then is where they
differ uh in the
in the background function case the
interface call background function
um that parameter will be deserialized
into a java class that you provide
using the json framework so that makes
it a bit more convenient
to get at the contents of the json and
then in the second form
we just give you a string which is the
incoming json as is
and then you can parse that using
whatever framework you like
jackson or whatever so we've seen how to
write functions but now guillaume will
talk about how you build and deploy them
so let's see how we can do that there
are a couple of options for building
functions your functions can be built
in the cloud from sources using maven
or gradle build tools your sources
should provide a palm.xml file or
build.gradle project file you can also
build
a jar with any build tool that you want
either a shaded jar with dependencies
within the jaw file or a jar archive
whose manifest
descriptor provides a class path
attribute pointing
at the jar dependencies in some local
subdirectory
with maven to build a java project
containing your functions your palm.xml
project build file must
import the functions framework api
dependency
this is actually a dependency which is
available on maven central
or jsenter it's a jar that provides the
various interfaces we've seen
representing
functions requests responses context etc
if you want to build with gradle
similarly to maven you need to have a
build.gradle file
with the functions framework api
dependency as well so here the
dependency is split over two lines
it's really just for a readability
purpose and that's all
when you deploy this project on cloud
functions the platform will take care
of the build for you
you can then deploy uh your functions
from either the
the google cloud console ui from the
gcloud command line
or with the maven function plugin we
provide a dedicated plugin for that
in the gcloud command here notice the
java
11 runtime runtime flag
which proves that we're indeed using
this new runtime also note the
entry point it corresponds to the fully
qualified class name
of your java function now that we've
seen
what functions look like i let emon tell
you more about the developer experience
so in common with all of the other
runtimes on gcf
we have a notion of a functions
framework
and that is basically that the code that
we the framework that we use to run your
function when you deploy it to gcf
is also available as an open source
project
on github you can download that and
build it and you can
run your function of course by deploying
it but you can also run it locally on
your machine
using this functions framework so
and you can also use that to package the
function
and into a container and deploy and
deploy that container wherever you like
to execute the function wherever you
like so what this looks like
in maven for example is that in your
pond.xml we supply you with a plugin
that makes this a little bit easier that
is based on top of the functions
framework
if you put this extract of code into
your
pom.xml then you can just type on the
command line
maven function colon run we already saw
this this plugin in action
to you to deploy the function with maven
function call and deploy
here you can use maven function call and
run and then you can interac interact
with your function which
again is just http you can interact with
it you know
either from your browser or from the
command line using curl or from tests or
whatever you like
let's come back to our prime number
function
which allowed us to know whether a
number was prime or not
i define the build the build
file for maven the pom.xml file
and there's a step that i skipped i
didn't explain
that's this part so this is where
we are actually configuring the function
maven
plugin okay we're defining a parameter
for this plugin
say the function target that's the
function we want to run with the
function maven plugin that's
this prime number function from my com
xfn
package and if i go into
the terminal and run mvn function
run it's going to run my function
locally on my machine
and it's already running locally and i
can
again for example i can do a curl
request locally here
19 is a prime number one two three four
is not a prime number okay
so it's very simple just define
the the maven function plugin
configuration here in your pum.xml file
and you're able to run your function
locally in your terminal on your
laptop on your desktop without having to
deploy
in the in the cloud actually we've been
talking about
java so far but you're not limited to
just the java language you can also run
and use alternative jvm languages for
authoring your functions
for instance you can use apache groovy
kotlin
scala or jruby thanks to uh
java thanks to its java virtual machine
is a
java is actually a platform where you
can run alternative languages as well
and you can do that with cloud functions
for java as well
so let's take an example here is an http
function
example using the apache groovy
programming language
it looks pretty similar to our java
example from earlier
same approach just implement the http
function interface and use the http
request
the http response parameters to inspect
incoming requests and
reply back to the calling client that's
also the same approach with background
functions when
you implement the background function or
the raw background function
interfaces so let's see a concrete
example with a demo
let's have a look at a groovy function
it's a useful function this time not a
hello world
which is going to parse um a file
using the ascii doctor format a file
that is hosted on github and which lists
the the official java champions so it's
a table
with different lines and showing the
pictures details names etc
town country this file is using the
ascii doctor
format which is format text format
similar to a
markdown um each row
for each champion looks something like
this you've got some links you've got
again country year etc
and the goal of my function is to output
something that is easier to parse for
tools
and i'm going to output json list
of documents so i want to transform
that into this basically so let's have a
look at
the the code so here's my groovy
function
i'm implementing the http function
interface
as usual i'm i have a service method
with a request and a response object
i'm doing things like adding a header
for cache control
setting the content type and then i'm
going to output some
json data i also have a look at the path
because i can sort my
java champions by year by country
and what's interesting as well look at
this and
that same thing uh below we're using
um the the groovy
equivalent of lum javalonda expressions
that's groovy closures
so here we are grouping by date sorting
by
key that's the the the name
the country and uh again the the key
here
so this is groovy notation basically
right
and uh what else easily i can
fetch the um the document that i'm going
to parse
and then i'm using the ascii doctor j
library
to parse the document and i go through
the the various
blocks of of text to create champions
instances of champions which have a name
twitter alias town country etc so how do
i do that
so let's have a look at my palm dot xml
file this time
i add a new plugin that's the gmail plus
plugin which is used to compile
groovycode you have to instruct
your maven build to say okay i also want
to
compile some groovy code along with java
code potentially
so that's the first plugin the other
plugin that's the
google cloud functions maven plugin and
i'm saying okay this is the function to
run
if i want to run the function locally
let's have a look at the dependencies
now
still the functions framework api
which is a provided dependency but since
i'm using the groovy language i'm adding
the groovy
library here and i also add the ascii
doctor j library
library for passing the the document
what's interesting with this function is
that actually
this is a groovy function using some
java libraries but also asc doctor j
which is actually
a ruby library which is interpreted with
the jruby
alternative jvm language so you have
basically three languages
java groovy ruby at the same time
running
with cloud functions for java so let's
continue on this
polyglot journey with another language
here again that's the same thing but
this time
using the kotlin programming language
that's pretty similar you have to
implement the http function interface
use the http request and response object
that's
pretty much the same thing except of
course that the syntax
of the long wait is slightly different
alternative languages check but you're
not
logged to the functions framework api
it's also possible to use
familiar frameworks like sprint cloud
micro node
quarkus using their own programming
models to create functions
for the java 11 runtime for cloud
functions so let's
have a look spring cloud
spring boot have a different approach to
creating functions
in spring a function is a spring beam
that returns
java function interface which is
parameterized by
an input type and output type your
spring functions
return the lambda expression hence the
arrow that you see here in this example
but you don't use the functions
framework api directly
you use springs programming model
instead
another framework this time micro node
for http functions
the micronet framework actually uses its
own annotation driven programming model
so you can see here we are defining a
controller
the path path variables etc reusing the
annotations provided by the micro node
framework this is really just a plain
micro node controller but the micronet
team provided
a specific cloud functions integration
that
wraps the functions framework interfaces
so micro node developers just author a
normal a plain usual micro node
controller
using their programming model um that
they are used to which is
pretty portable because this controller
can run elsewhere
in a container as a web application and
not just as a cloud function
let's have a look at the concrete
example with
the micro nodes framework so what does a
microneed function looks like
i'm actually going to use a project
called micronut launch
which has been created by the micronut
team to scaffold
a new project a template for for your
project
so you can select uh what you want to
create which language you want to use
which bill which kind of testing tool
and you can also add features so i
already added it
initially there's a specific feature for
google cloud function so the micro team
created an integration for
cloud functions java 11. so you can
click the generate button to generate
an archive zip file for your project but
you can also click the little preview
button to see what's generated
a controller uh there's even a docker
file if you run
that if you want to run the that
function that application that micro
node application elsewhere for example
uh as a cloud run container that's
possible and there's also
um build but i've already
uh downloaded this
and so i have a build.gradle file that's
been generated using the functions
framework api
the invoker that's what allows you to
run functions
locally or invoke your functions
anywhere
and what's interesting is that there's a
a special task that's been added here
run function which does the same job as
the maven function plugin
which is using the invoker to run the
function locally and it's
going to call the integration point
created by the micro node folks
the http function which is going to
delegate delegate the work to the
hello controller so this controller it's
a standard micro node controller using
the
add controller annotation you can
looking at the
slash hello sub path it's going to
output some
plain text let's write something
gcf java 11 rocks
let's save this and then let's run that
locally so it's going to
build this function locally and run it
locally using
the functions invoker and the through
the gradle build
um so let's have a look uh yeah gcf java
11 rocks
so unlike spring cloud and micro node
quackers
follows the function framework native
api approach just
decorating uh functions with quarker's
specific annotations like
at named at application scope or at
inject to do dependency
injection for the uh dependencies that
are needed for
your function this is also the same
approach
uh for background functions so taking
advantage of quarkx annotations
but following the functions framework
api using the
functions framework api interfaces
instead
so that's about it i let eman conclude
so we saw a rapid tour of gcf java so
java is one of the new
runtimes available with gcf now
we saw that there are two kinds of
functions http functions and background
functions
that functions are portable thanks to
the functions framework so you can
deploy
apply them using the functions framework
in production
to gcf but you can also run them locally
and you can
put them in a container and deploy them
anywhere you want we saw that it isn't
really just a java runtime it's a jvm
runtime so you can run
any jvm language such as kotlin
or groovy and finally we saw that it
works not only uh on its own but also in
conjunction with a certain number of
other frameworks such as spring cloud
quarkus
and micronaut so that's gcf java and
we're excited to see what you'll do with
it